[Música]
até onde a música pode te levar vocês já
pensaram sobre isso até onde a música
pode levar você até a qual a trilha
sonora da sua vida
enfim eu tenho algumas perguntas antes
de começar o que a gente fala muito
sobre música a gente ouvir algumas
músicas também então vim trazer música
pra vocês
a gente vai eu vou começar algumas
perguntas está em primeiro é você já eu
já sei a resposta de vocês mas vou fazer
vou fingir que não tá é você já ficou
indeciso e em algum momento da sua vida
e não sabia que caminho seguir por
exemplo ou que aquela alternativa que
estava ali do lado direito ali te dava
medo de seguir você foi para a esquerda
então acho que a gente vai falar sobre
isso e e eu disser pra vocês que para
cada momento da vida de vocês
existe uma música uma trilha sonora a
música é o sentido da vida é todo se
todos nós somos seres musicais então
vamos falar sobre o sentido da vida
minha história começa em 78 a 78 a gente
espera que se sente obrigado isso mas a
minha a minha história como é 78 é que
foi quando meus pais se conheceram 1 70
em maio de 68
é mas a toda a minha fala aqui na hoje
pra vocês é baseado no billboard top 1
da billboard tá então em 78 o primeiro
lugar da billboard
era essa música e foi quem reviu da
yvone é limã eu vou passar um trechinho
pra vocês vocês conhecem só para
refrescar um pouco a memória tá beleza o
bonitinho é fofinho né e foi quem viu
meu pai junto 178 acho que ilustra bem
essa primeira usina número 1 da
billboard que conta bastante um momento
de um casal né
então se eu não tiver você eu não quero
ninguém fim e aí passa pra 83 que foi o
ano em que meus pais se casaram
música número 1 da billboard ora feeling
que sentimento enfim eles se casaram
fala bastante sobre é você se sentir bem
com a situação de você ter confiança e
fechar os olhos e seguir em frente
então acho que ilustra bastante também
meus pais são dois apaixonados por
música meu pai baterista minha mãe era
dona de casa quando se casaram e aí dois
anos depois em 85
esse serzinho nasceu em 22 de novembro
de 1985 a primeira música no dia do dia
22 de novembro mesmo dia 22
é uma música de uma banda chamada
starship com a música wild siri
construção de coisas a construção de
vida ou são da família enfim acho que é
interessante eu sou o primeiro passo da
da família da construção da minha
família então e na se envolvido com
alguém ou então acho que tem alguma
relação comigo também 85
é como falei anteriormente de passe sai
do meu pai
o baterista e eu ganhei minha primeira
bateria com cinco anos de idade
foi meu primeiro instrumento é depois
obra tive banda horrível nem vou falar o
nome agora é preciso procurar no google
banda delay 17 até ser censurada que vai
ter um bip no nome da banda eae teve
banda é isso com 13 13 anos 10 anos
enfim logo no começo da data da minha
adolescência e aí teve um primeiro ponto
de virada na minha vida que eu acho que
foi a um gancho bem importante também
para os próximos para os nossos próximos
acontecimentos
esse gancho acontece em 1991 que é a
separação dos meus pais o divórcio dos
meus pais
tá então a música é o álbum top 1 na
billboard era um foguete bowes love da
natalie cole
então o que é uma música que você deve
conhecer natalie cole filha e do neto
king cole
então vou tocar se vocês não conhecem
por favor pode levantar o título venha
bem legal
existe algo inesquecível e tal e finta
frase bem marcante
passamos o ano de 2003 a gente teve um
bom golpe e de ano mas em 2003 é uma
fase muito importante pra mim é especial
é passado ensino médio tudo escola etc
chegou a hora de escolher o meu curso
que eu ia fazer da vida eu escolhi um
curso que tem tudo a ver com isso aqui
que foi medicina tem nada a ver né então
passei pelo curso de medicina passe pelo
cursinho fazendo pra chegar até virar
médico tem o doutor aqui todavia médico
cheguei na hora de preencher o
formulário do vestibular
eu escolhi audiovisual tá então
audiovisual foi minha primeira escolha
e aí e enfim começar no vestibular
fazendo vestibular correndo e tal eu
passei em algumas faculdades ea minha
escolha foi pela faap
então escolha fábio pela estrutura e
dissera na época mas filho de pais
separados
é difícil é a situação financeira era na
época
e aí eu comentei com a qual o meu guru
que a minha mãe falei pra ela seguinte
foi mãe ao fap está pesado né não você
vai ter que enfim fazer o que treinamos
lá
preciso de uma bolsa além da bolsa que
eles já davam por eu ter sido bem
colocado no vestibular etc
cheguei
cheguei aqui fiz a a consulta e teve um
pequeno detalhe em quando cheguei aqui
na faap que eles não queriam me da bolsa
e as impedir de estar aqui com vocês mas
o que foi falado é que a faculdade não
era pra mim
o curso não era pra eu tá aqui então
passar o tempo
minha mãe brigando com a central de
bolsas aqui da faap até conseguir uma
bolsa decente pra eu entrar aqui
conseguimos uma porcentagem boa
comecei o curso
no dia 3 de novembro de 2003 é foi
recebendo disse que tinha passado e que
eu ia conseguir cursar a faculdade 2004
tá o primeiro álbum da billboard em 2003
é esse aqui médio europa - à medida de
um homem
então é um cantor não muito conhecido
participou da segunda temporada do
américa na ilha do leite
mas eu acho que essa música fala muito
sobre esse momento de 2003 uma frase
muito marcante da música que a gente tem
tudo a ver com esse momento e enfim
conseguiram aqui com vocês hoje e aqui
um ponto passei toda a faculdade é no
segundo semestre da faculdade eu comecei
a meu estágio eu não sei quantos alunos
têm aqui na platéia mas achei um ponto
importante também no segundo semestre já
da faculdade comecei meu estágio também
que tinha superávit com isso eu comecei
no instituto de pesquisas
socioeconômicas
então ea idéia as caras foi pra cima
comecei a trabalhar com comunicação e em
2007 eu em 2006 eu recebi uma proposta
de um programa super hi pago de
televisão na época para ser produtor
externa do programa
consultei mais uma vez minha mãe ea
gente chegou a um consenso que não
deveria sair da onde eu estava hoje no
instituto
na época né em 2007 eu fui convidado por
uma das das maiores agências do brasil
na época para trabalhar em uma agência
de publicidade foi o primeiro contato
com publicidade na época era giovanni
draft fcb hoje deve ser brasil
então trabalhei nunca tive a
oportunidade de trabalhar na logo de
início na primeira no meu primeiro
emprestado em publicidade na uma das
maiores agências do brasil do país
passei por outra agência no final depois
foi para o grupo da publicis até é
receber a bela notícia que foi e todos
um grupo foi convidado a se retirar da
agência demissão voluntária e aí eu
falei pô vou fazer o quê agora né
na época eu prestava fila de culpa na
gente sabe que a clonagem
tá eu pegava o cupom de uma marca de
comida chinesa é pegava caixas de cupons
de papel que eles culpam se preenche pra
praia viajar ganha carro etc
pegava sujo de show lá ocupou letra do
médico ia lá pegava e tentava adivinhar
o nome do cara e tabular tudo no excel
eram 25 mil cupons 30 mil cupons e aí eu
comecei a enxergar que eu não daria
conta disso tudo foi o que vou fazer se
modificou todo sujo
vou começar a contratar gente para me
ajudar com isso repartir um pouco da
grana que era uma grana boa e começou um
pouco eu descobri o dna de empreendedor
eu falei pô isso aqui faz sentido pra
mim eu gosto quero continuar com isso e
passar do tempo os meses a o marketing
do meu primeiro cliente é que a morana a
maior marca de acessórios femininos hoje
no brasil amy chamou de lado e falou da
você trabalha com música da apple até
que enfim alguém falar de música é
trabalha com música por que você não faz
um music branding da morana
eu falei eu não sei o que é música do
brasil
mas posso tentar foi estudar foi atrás
fora do brasil aqui no brasil alguns
players do mercado que faziam esse
trabalho eu falei pô legal gostei pra
caramba tem superconexão comigo
trabalhei com publicidade
sou de uma família musical pra caramba
gosto de música sou músico toca bateria
apesar de algumas pessoas acharem que o
baterista não é músico uma raiva eu toco
bateria tudo foi por legal pra caramba e
em 2009 no dia 15 de setembro de 2009
eu fundei a tireóide de itatiba dia que
a agência que eu tenho hoje é completar
dez anos esse ano tá no dia 15 de
setembro de 2009
a música número 1 da billboard é essa
agora feeling seguir a intuição
você tem alguma o passarinho ele falando
as orelhas que isso vai dar certo e no
final deu certo e eu fui fazer fazer por
fazer por fazer e fui fazer e fui fazer
e fui fazer até
aqui tá hathway de que a minha agência
hoje trabalha com cerca de 40 marcas no
mercado grandes marcas do varejo há como
eu falei vai completar dez anos de
setembro desse ano a gente já tem de
cerca de duas mil e 500 lojas no brasil
e fora do brasil então um ponto muito
importante para a gente montar essa
história toda
mas o que eu quero o que eu queria
passar de mensagem para vocês que já
está chegando também no final é ouviu
todo tudo que tem à sua volta não só
música mas ouvir tudo o que tem à sua
volta mas principalmente tratar isso com
o coração seguir o que está aqui ouvir
as pessoas e ouvir o que está à volta de
vocês tentar filtrar o que o que está
acontecendo e aí sim colocar aqui dentro
e colocar isso pra funcionar tá e foi
isso que eu fiz desde 85 desde que ela
se de repente até em 78 tattoo e um
ponto importante também é 2019
a música número 1 da billboard não é que
eu trouxe pra vocês dessa vez eu trouxe
a segunda música da billboard para vocês
o rapper e eu não poderia estar mais
feliz aqui com vocês hoje
obrigado